- It legit tastes like blueberries.
- If you marinated blueberries in,
I don't know, semen for a week maybe.
(soft country music)
- [Woman] So today we're
trying bizarre sodas.
- Like pizza soda?
- Oh no.
- Is there like a vomit flavored soda?
Cause I will spit that at you.
- I've had a sip of bacon flavored soda.
- How was it?
- It was horrible.
- Okay this smells like
medicine right now.
- Its really good.
- Well I wouldn't go that far.
- I can't taste anything.
- Oh butter.
- I think it's like bread.
- What?
Peanut butter?
That tasted nothing like
peanut butter and jelly.
- It does.
- I just wish there's a crunch in it.
- Bread was involved.
- This is not lychee.
- No smell some lychee in this.
- What?
- It's fine for a second and then it's
the worst thing in the world.
(screams)
- That's butter popcorn for sure
- Corn.
- [Both] Sweet corn!
- You keep drinking it.
- I kinda like it.
- This is straight up pee.
- This does not look like my pee at all.
I don't know what, you
need to drink more water.
- Oh.
I know what this smells like.
- Oh it's awful.
- No.
No.
- It tastes kinda good.
- You're wrong.
I think it's socks.
- I'm gonna guess blueberry pie.
- You (bleep)!
- Ranch dressing.
- That is not ranch.
- Do you like ranch?
- I did.
- Oh (bleep)!
Smell it.
That's bacon.
(gags)
- Wait that ones throw up for sure.
- Point that way.
(gagging)
- No, no, no.
- Well I don't think it's bacon.
- If ugly had a taste it would be this.
- You know I think it's Sharpie.
(gagging)
- Cranberry?
- It was bacon.
(laughing)
- That doesn't even smell like bacon.
Bacon smells good.
- This is the worst soda I've
ever tasted in my whole life.
- 10 minutes ago we were happy people.
- We were happy people.
Our breath smelled so good.
- I would buy them to give it to a friend
that I really didn't like.
- I like the first three.
- The first three?
I'd maybe go for the first one.
I need a real soda to wash
this taste out of my mouth.
(soft instrumental music)